"The Witcher" games, and the ultra-popular
"The Witcher III: The Wild Hunt" in particular,
have given many fans a very definitive depiction
of Andrzej Sapkowski's mysterious Continent
and its many strange denizens.
As such, Netflix's live-action adaptation
of "The Witcher" was always going to be a
tough balancing act.
How to recreate a world that millions of players
have already obsessed over for countless hours
in a familiar, yet fresh way?
How to create the sense of danger that the
game's many powerful enemies and monsters
radiate?
And how, oh how, could anyone hope to capture
the gruff energy of the main character, Geralt
of Rivia?
Though he's best known for his comparatively
clean-cut turn as the DC Extended Universe
version of Superman, Cavill absolutely nails
the essence of Geralt.
The actor prepared extensively for the role,
transforming his body to better suit its needs
and, of course, delivering his lines with
that signature growl.
However, he has now revealed that one important
aspect in his character work happened completely
by accident.
Yeah, that iconic voice Cavill uses in "The
Witcher?"
As he revealed during CD PROJECT RED and Netflix's
virtual WitcherCon, it was a total mistake
on the actor's part.
He simply forgot what kind of voice he was
supposed to use partway through the shoot,
and after he heard what he sounded like in
a scene with King Foltest, he was delighted
— but also slightly worried, because he
initially felt the delivery was a bit too
close to voice actor Doug Cockle's performance
in "The Witcher" games.
Cavill said,
"I know it's very similar to Doug Cockle's
amazing work.
That was definitely a concern of mine.
I thought, 'Well, I don't want to seem like
I'm plagiarizing another professional's extraordinary
work.'
And I had a look at it, had a listen to it,
and I thought, 'actually, they are different
enough.
It's clearly inspired by [Cockle's version]
— but I did my own thing.'"
There was just one problem: They had already
shot some scenes for the show.
Fortunately, the powers that be liked Cavill's
new take on the voice so much that they offered
to reshoot the scenes.
Seeing as the combination of Geralt's harsh
voice, strange accent, and quiet nature play
a large part in his characterization, it's
probably fair to say that this was the right
call.
Series creator Lauren Schmidt Hissrich knew
that the role of Geralt would be one quite
sought after, but she also knew that she was
going for a certain iconic voice to bring
the character to the screen.
Hissrich told us here at Looper,
"At the end of the day, though, I realized
that I actually kind of had Henry Cavill's
voice in my head, and I called him and explained
basically this whole thing."
So although he found his Geralt voice by a
happy accident, the actor's voice was a factor
before he was even officially cast for the
show!
Nevertheless, Cavill refused to outright accept
the part, as he shared Hissrich's philosophy
that the production should seek far and wide
for its Geralt.
Hissrich said,
"And he was like, 'Great, if you want me,
I want you to know that I'm the right person.
I want you to have seen everyone and met everyone.
And we met up again and we and talked for
several hours.
And by the time we left that day, I knew that
I had found our Geralt."
In the end, Cavill ended up coming out on
top in a casting process that Hissrich said
involved "207 potential Geralts" — and that
was before the actor even found the character's
iconic voice.
Not bad!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Witcher
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.